make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
hello everyone and welcome back to
beyond omega-level in this video we're
covering a character that you all have
been requesting and all the people on
discord and patreon have been requesting
superboy-prime now here's a funny thing
plug about patreon um I know a lot of
you guys are kind of unsure about the
vs. videos in terms of whether or not
it's worth investing in on patreon the
last verses video we did was was
Franklin Richards versus dr. Manhattan
the next one we're doing is Franklin
Richards vs. Matthew Molloy and then I
think after that we'll do Matthew Molloy
vs. dr. Manhattan to see who would win
in a battle between these two characters
I think it's cool like we're just doing
like super like like super heavy hitters
versus super heavy hitters like super
pacs we're like overpowered here tyr's
you guys seem to love those for some
reason and it is crazy like overpowered
characters versus overpowered characters
admittedly I love those kind of
characters too but and this one we're
doing superboy-prime now for those of
you guys who have newly arrived to the
planet Earth from whatever world you're
from and don't know who's superboy-prime
is he was created by Elliot s Megan and
Curt Swan and made his first appearance
in DC Comics presents number 87 in 1985
but he wouldn't actually use the name
superboy-prime until Infinite Crisis
number 2 and 2006 by Geoff Johns
now to understand Super Why prawn we
first have to be familiar with the
concept of the DC multiverse which is
made up of multiple universes each with
his own version of earth no
superboy-prime is actually the kal-el
from earth prime which is the DC Comics
version of our earth the real world
where characters like Superman Batman
and Wonder Woman are fictitious heroes
now the child that would become Superboy
prom was adopted by Giri
and Naomi Kim and given the name Clark
now as it turns out Clark was actually
kal-el from the planet Krypton in Earth
pran and just like the version of
Superman that we all know was sent to
Earth by his parents just before Krypton
was incinerated by its Sun now Clark
grew up normally until the age of 15
when Halley's Comet passed over earth
now when the comet passed it triggered
Clark's Kryptonian powers and made him
into Earth's version of Superman and so
superboy-prime has all the powers that
the version of Superman were all
familiar with has superhuman strength
speed and endurance flight
invulnerability x-ray vision heat vision
frost breath all the stuff that Superman
can do however because magic does not
exist on earth Prime Superboy does not
have
a weakness to it as the main universe
Superman does and is also not weakened
by the Kryptonite of new earth the
reality that exists after crisis on
Infinite Earths because he was not from
that reality now eventually Prime Earth
is destroyed by the anti-monitor during
crisis on Infinite Earths and Superboy
battles alongside the heroes of other
universes to defeat the anti-monitor now
after the battle and with the
anti-monitor defeated Superboy
goes to the Paradise dimension along
with the Superman and Lois Lane of Earth
- and Alexander Luthor the son of earth
threes Lex Luthor now he spends years in
the Paradise dimension never aging but
coming to resent the fact that he'd been
robbed of his youth and would never grow
up to become Superman and so because he
just sits in the alternate dimension and
gets angrier and more bitter he
eventually decides along with Alexander
Luthor to escape the Paradise dimension
and come to the main DC Universe by
literally punching the barrier of
reality that separates these two
dimensional spaces and so this punch is
not only the first indication of how
powerful superboy-prime is but it also
sends ripple effects throughout the DC
Universe changing aspects of DC's
continuity and its wake most notably
bringing Red Hood Jason Todd back to
life merging the origins of Superman
into the main continuity and rebooting
the Doom Patrol
among others now what this means is that
superboy-prime is powerful enough to
alter reality in addition to all the
powers that he already possessed as his
universes Superman now Superboy and
Alexander's entry into the main universe
brings about the infinite crisis event
and it's here that we see some of the
most impressive displays of Superboy
paratus powers for instance he alters
the orbits of several planets including
moving the planet rond so close to the
planet thanagar the thanagar environment
is destroyed and the two planets go to
war he's also able to move the center of
the universe away from OA the homeworld
of the guardians of the universe
Superboy goes on to blow up the Justice
League of America's watchtower and
kidnaps and subdues and then eventually
kills Martian Manhunter and Omega level
character on his own on par with
Superman at one point Superboy is taken
into the Phantom Zone a pocket universe
that serves as a prison for some of the
most powerful entities in the DC
Universe and pulling off a feat that was
thought to be impossible
Superboy punches his way out of the
Phantom Zone once again altering reality
in the process this time as it's related
to the origin of Beast Boy now later we
get to see just how ridiculously fast
Superboy pond is when he's trapped in
the Speed Force by basically every
speedster in the DC Universe and it's
stated the superboy-prime is faster than
Wally West who at the time was believed
to be the fastest among all the
speedsters now while in the Speed Force
Superboy is trapped for years under the
light of red Suns which dampened his
power significantly but he's eventually
able to free himself from the Speed
Force by constructing a Power Suit that
captured and stored the energy of yellow
Suns now the fact that he was able to do
this seemingly impossible feat shows us
that Superboy Ron is basically the
picture you see in the dictionary next
to the word overpowered but Superboy's
feats do not stop there he also
dispatches the Justice Society of
America the Teen Titans and the Doom
Patrol all at the same time and liddy
remarks that he wasn't even trying when
he battled them and was also unfazed by
a punch from Black Adam now eventually
superboy-prime is captured and
imprisoned in a quantum containment
field on the planet OA with a junior red
Sun eager to dampen his powers and is
guarded by fifty Green Lantern's at all
times and he would later be freed from
this prison by the Sinestro Corps and
would fight the heroes of Earth in the
Sinestro Corps award alongside the Corps
as a minion of the anti-monitor men
during this time he fights so DeMott a
member of the Green Lantern Corps that
has been amped up by the ion symbiote
that increases the power of those it
bonds with and it should also be noted
that sodam yacht is add action like an
extra dimensional race descended from
Kryptonians mean that he basically has
all the powers of Superman the to fight
pretty evenly until they find themselves
in a nuclear power plant the lead used
to contain the radiation from the power
plant severely weakened sodam yacht and
superboy-prime nearly kills him later
during the same event Superboy survives
the world war bomb explosion which was
powerful enough to destroy the entire
galaxy and also ripped the anti-monitor
to shreds and throws him to the end of
the universe now although the
anti-monitor
is weakened this is still quite an
impressive feat given the anti-monitor
is well beyond Omega level himself now
finally after Superboy was thwarted by
the combined efforts of DC's heroes
along with the guardians of the universe
and a last-ditch effort one of the
Guardians tries to destroy Superboy
by self-destructing but this only serves
to make Superboy even more powerful as
he absorbs the power of the Guardian now
in this form we see superboy-prime at a
whole new level of power as he kills the
Superman from Earth 15 which is
basically on the same level as the main
universe Superman and likewise kills
that Earth's Batman and dispenses with
his Wonder Woman in
yet now he eventually destroys the
entire earth and everyone on it and
suggested it could tear the multiverse
apart if he wanted to he even manages to
make his way to the fifth dimension and
kidnap mr. mixup Italy which is
absolutely crazy because mixi is one of
the most powerful reality workers in DC
and prime just takes him and in subdues
and tortures him to force him into his
bidding although it does appear that
mixi was somewhat weakened now in this
form superboy-prime is feared by the
monitors which are nearly omnipotent
cosmic beans he also fights monarch
another crazy powerful entity that it
absorbed the powers of all the captain
atoms from various earths and when
Superman rips his Armour open it
destroys the entire universe of earth 51
in fact the only thing that we see
capable of destroying superboy-prime is
when he meets himself from a 31st
century they fight and superboy-prime
punches his older self and the younger
one fades from existence
and so yeah superboy-prime is really
just like this super amped up version of
Superman with none of the weaknesses a
Superman has traditionally had the thing
is it's never really explained why
superboy-prime seems so much stronger
than the main universe version of
Superman in the first place it's easy to
explain when he's absorbed the power of
the guardians of the universe and even
when he has a power suit that collects
yellow sun energy but even then it's not
explained how he made that suit in
Infinite Crisis but initially it's not
made clear if the discrepancy is based
on Superboy primes insanity that
develops inside the Paradise dimension
or the fact that he simply Superman
who's just not holding back
in any event he's definitely omega-level
as we've seen by the laundry list of
ridiculous feats that he's performed and
yes I'm aware that later he gets beat up
by the Teen Titans and trapped in the
source wall but honestly that just seems
wildly inconsistent with how he was
previously written so I view this is
more of an outlier than is a true
representation of his power level but
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
with the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I feel like we should do a video on
Superboy prom at his Mac's at his peak
against dr. Manhattan well I think we're
gonna do that on patreon so glad that
you said guys whatever in this video to
an end and I will catch you while later
purse I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B we have little
Austin's and our patreon as well as G
gnosis 916 de gnosis didn't give us the
first and last name so we kind of had to
go with it I didn't mention your all's
last names I think you guys didn't want
me to throw them out there but I want to
say thank you to you all by the way
you're robbed four rings should be on
their way for our honor guard members of
the robbed core for these special
patrons your custom robbed four rings
should be on their way they're being
shipped to me after that I will have
them shipped to you stay tuned keep your
eye on patreon in your messages and you
will hear about them coming to you thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]